the Joe Rogan experience I knew you just
maintaining now you're trying to canal
maintaining like I'm on the road for the
next like sixty well we have sixty three
dates with Jay and Silent Bob reboot
we've just been in Jersey Chicago
Detroit Grand Rapids Saint Paul st.
Louis Columbus as the first leg and now
we go to Texas and stuff we're doing
that for like 60s publicity tour
we're just touring the movie rather than
like I will put the movie out in 1,000
theaters we don't have that kind of
marketing money
so instead me and Jay are just touring
with the movie so essentially it's like
a comedy tour or like a small punk band
tour we go to a theater we set up shop
we sold tickets in advance a lot of the
tourists sold out reboot Roadshow come
for tickets and we intro the movie watch
the movie with them and then hang out
afterwards Q&A chat Linda and for me
it's like you know it's pretty grueling
schedules every day in a different city
but every day I get to like sit and
watch the movie with the exact audience
it was made for it's not like walking
into a multiplex that's playing your
movie and even if it's crowded you're
like man I hope all these cats get every
joke and stuff this is the crowd the
movie was made for so every reference
every joke like Landsman you feel like a
genius I sit in the back of the room and
watch the back of our heads like a dirty
little [ __ ] at every screening man just
ready to [ __ ] a jerk off him so happy
with myself I'm like I'm so clever
listening doesn't laugh it's you know
it's like stand-up but like with the
movies and you know it's not it's we've
just taken the movie and kind of event
eyes dit and by being like hey man come
watch it with us because you do that
that's very cool
and in a world where people would come
see me and J anyway talk about the old
movies like em pay fifty two hundred
bucks for like they pay the same thing
see just bring a new [ __ ] movie so
it's been incredibly successful man like
big sold-out shows we've had to like
double up on shows but watching it with
the audience is like it's it's it's
fantastic you guys do a Q&A or
afterwards no and I trib wait we share
the stage which is difficult because I
tend to you know as you see like I'm
blah blah blah so I've tried to hold
back to let him kind of take front and
center
the kunayak sees the start of the movie
and he's amazing in the [ __ ] flick
like I tell people at the beginning of
every night I'm like I we only get to
make this journey and we've been doing
it for 25 years since clerks because
like I met a boy who said dirty things
to me and I said come with me we're
going to Hollywood and like I met a true
American original Jason Mewes who I said
you I think you're funny I wonder if
people would find you funny outside of
New Jersey and like somebody should put
you in a movie one day and then one day
I was that person and he was our
passport and has been our passport to
the world the guy least likely the guy
that was never gonna get out of
Highlands you know on his own accord but
like simply by being like wait say these
things here on camera now we've got a
movie like he opened up the entire world
to us so it's his finest hour in this
movie like he's funny as [ __ ] and he
cares the whole show but he also gets to
be emotional because it's about him
finding out he's got a long-lost
daughter and [ __ ] so it's
father-daughter movie and and so there
are moments in the movie where people
cry and not because like Kevin [ __ ] up
another movie like they're like oh my
god like he's he's getting me there as
an actor it's been like [ __ ]
thrilling to watch so every night like
it was thrilling to watch when we made
it every night I get to like sit back
and watch the audience take it in and
I'm used to making comedy and you want
people laughing otherwise you if it's
silence its death but there are moments
in the movie where like it's quiet and
that's a good thing and like you know I
still clench my [ __ ] because and any
silence you're always like you just need
one heckler to be like [ __ ] this blows
or whatever in the audience breaks or
whatever so far man it's been like
really [ __ ] beat he's put the seat
out there though the [ __ ] this blows you
know no no out of my mouth I was like
damn your self we're going to Houston
tomorrow night
[Applause]